bientôt ce centre culturel et
communautaire sera nuit à nouveau après
des semaines d'activités offertes en
ligne oui content de pouvoir faire face
à des vrais êtres humains mais en même
temps nous essayons de garder quand même
les prêts les mesures de précaution
c'est à dire le port du masque quand on
sera dans une situation de regroupement
le lavage fréquent des mains le respect
d'une distance sécuritaire la prise de
température
en fait le gouvernement invite les
citoyens à poursuivre plusieurs
comportements recommandé depuis le début
de l'épidémie car il insiste la guerre
contre la copie 19 n'est pas terminée
dans un guide mise en ligne avec force
détails
il en appelle à suivre une distanciation
de routine
c'est vraiment gestion cas par cas en
prenant compte de la vulnérabilité de
chacun d'entre nous à commencer par les
personnes âgées et les enfants par
exemple rester à la maison quelques
jours si on se sent le moindrement
malades prendre la rame de métro
suivante si les voitures sont bondés
beaucoup d'employeurs avait opté pour le
télétravail les horaires réaménagés au
plus fort de la crise le gouvernement
les enjoint de privilégier le téléphone
l'internet pour les réunions
d'information de désinfecter locaux et
bureaux
ça vaut aussi pour tous qui reprend
graduellement
c'est le cas des événements sportifs
dont le baseball professionnel huis clos
pour l'instant et des lieux et
établissements publics dont les écoles
primaires et secondaires de me retrouver
ici à pouvoir sortir à dimanche à
débrancher rebrancher avec des amis en
échange d'une liberté de mouvement et
sud coréens ont largement respecté une
distanciation social street view sont
suivis parce que le gouvernement a
espéré confiance en étant transparent
dans sa gestion de la crise estime ce
sociologue
l'obligation du port de masse et est
parfois vécue comme un peu
disproportionnées par rapport à la
situation qu'on vivait et la cour étant
quand même une société assez homogène on
signe et voilà les beaux jours et
l'assouplissement des consignes de
distanciation comporte toutefois leur
lot de risque de relâchement
ici à nick berg radio canada cible